how're you doing I'm great thanks for uh
thanks for coming up here and doing this
I'm super happy to be here our mutual
friend Jeff Gordon here is the one who
keep me on to everything that you're up
to and I'm excited to talk to you man
I'm excited to talk to you all so yeah I
mean Jeff Jeff is Jefferson pretty
awesome dude and and is has been really
supportive has been a really good friend
- uh-huh
you did an event with him recently right
he came to an event that I was a part of
recently I did a reading near Jeff and I
live in the same town and and then
worked at details together for for many
years also so like a bunch of those
stories that he talked about when he was
right on your podcast Keanu Reeves
sandwich story the Keanu Reeves sandwich
story the sex doll repair right the
repair man that was that was details but
I did this event in New York and and
near where we live and Jeff came to show
his support yeah cool yeah he texted me
this morning just to make sure that I
was key you know like all up speed on
everything and and he he reminded me of
of just what a heyday it was at details
during that time I mean you were really
there at a period where magazines were
hyper relevant and you had quite you
know the long leash to work with all
kinds of amazing writers and really
indulge long-form storytelling in a way
that you just don't see that often now I
like to I like to think that that I got
to ride the last great wave of magazine
publishing now that's not to say that
there's still not great stuff going on
in magazines - because of course there
is but but back then when we relaunched
details in 2000 there were still huge
budgets like you said incredibly long
leash really the tons of autonomy the
ability to
to do what we wanted to do and send
writers off on crazy adventures and then
have them come back and publish you know
six seven eight thousand words which
which was you know which was a real
treat and it's something that's that's a
little bit more rare today and deploy
these amazing writers like I'm suffering
for and and augusten Burroughs who blurb
your book and like all these incredible
literary talents yeah so we were able to
sort of tap into that and give them the
opportunity to write and go for it
and and it seems like that has sort of
dried up a little bit you know obviously
but it really was it was it felt like a
golden era you know and and I was really
I'm super grateful to have to have been
a part of that you know well your story
and the book is you know it's sort of
equal parts it's it's like a a tone down
it's like a toned down version or the an
insecure person's telling of a bright
lights big city type narrative you know
what I mean like you're you mute the
kind of high wire act of editing this
you know very prominent magazine and
kind of navigating you know the the
canyons of lower Manhattan and all of
that but you know when I think about
like that time and what you were doing
it just I mean that was like a rockstar
job that you had it was and and one that
I was in no way ready for and that's not
like for humility like no no they
shouldn't have given it to me no they
shouldn't have given it to me but you
know I they gave me this job running
details I was 28 years old I had never
run any anything like that
we were running W in Paris prior to that
I was I was I was running W magazines
European bureaus prior to that but that
you know very was a very lean operation
you know by comparison right so then I
was given this job at details and and
you know moved back to New York and and
to kind of figure all of this stuff out
and had to hire a team and I had never
really done any of that before and
what's interesting is you're you don't
like sort of cut the figure of the
person you expect to be in that job
first of all you were super young but
you're like you know you talk about this
in the book like you're listening to
Hootie and the Blowfish even though you
were w like you don't really care about
fashion like how does this how do you
end up being in this arbiter of style
and culture well I you know I think just
just a quick word about my taste in
music because I've just been a Jeff must
give you a lot of shot man you have no
idea because he's got his taste is down
and and listen with all due respect to
Hootie and the Blowfish God love him you
know I wouldn't even put them that high
on my list I mentioned them in the book
rich during field but it was like it
totally it was like it was I'm a child
of the 80s right I was born in the 70s
but like I really started kind of like
absorbing culture in the 80s and so like
for me
in Baltimore you know it was stuff like
you know it was a journey and foreigner
and sticks and and and bands like that
and so that that just sort of stuck with
me so a journey in particular something
that people just like merciless about
when they are made and they tease me you
know cuz I hear you're right you're
absolutely right here I was now running
this magazine and I would have all these
editors who are plugged in some had
worked at Rolling Stone and spin and you
know they knew these worlds and they
would come to me to pitch stories on
bands that like I had just only maybe
even just heard of in some cases had not
heard of and then you have people like
Jeff and and others who were like music
right you know freaks and junkies you
know that were like oh man like can we
do something a little different a little
new agey or whatever the case may be but
yeah it wasn't it wasn't a job it wasn't
an hour I wasn't an obvious person for
that role but I think that's what what
led them to want to give it to me you
know I think they wanted to try
something different I think that the
men's magazine landscape at that time
was changing very quickly this was the
era of what we called the lad magazines
like Maxim and stuff and things like
that and pretty like TNA driven and and
things like that that just wasn't
necessarily something that appealed to
me right so I you know and and the team
that I assembled you know we came up
with this I concept basically of you
know creating a magazine for for men not
necessarily beer and babes and barbecue
and sports you know but but a new type
of guy who could stand on his own two
feet in lots of different ways and
didn't didn't need to have a woman and a
wet t-shirt on the cover of a magazine
in order for him to be like oh cool I'll
pick that up so we started to kind of
look at things a little differently yeah
it tapped the the metrosexual zeitgeist
nerve I suppose and it kind of gave guys
permission to care about things like
style and cool music and stuff and
skincare you uh do you did you know a
guy named Jamie Hooper who ran Maxim the
name sounds familiar but but no I mean
I'm a little bit older than you but he
was one of the guys that I ran around
New York with when I was in there like
way back in the day I feel like there
were but there were lots of guys like
like that and this was what and by the
way at this time in our culture right
around 2000 or even the late nineties
this this was all there was like this
was this stuff was booming we're
absolutely booming this was the the the
approach to to talking about masculinity
you know and it was like you know fart
jokes and and like the hottest women in
bikini competitions you know vote online
now you know and so like and that when I
looked at that I was like hey listen
that just doesn't like appeal to me you
know and and so so we kind of cobbled
together this magazine that you're right
I think tapped the metrosexual vein and
and allowed us to look at with
with a broader sort of filter things
that were affecting men's lives and
things that men should care about where
previously you you you didn't see too
many guys sort of like openly embracing
a love of you know aftershave or you
know or whatever cooking or architecture
or design whatever it is you know I
remember just sort of thinking as I
would page through that magazine around
that time during that period of time
like is this for gay dudes or is this
for me like is this like you know it was
sorry I'm sort of it had a gay slant but
it wasn't overtly gay like it was meant
to kind of capture that audience but
also be broader that's it that's exactly
right it was it was meant to sort of
smash the stereotype of what what's a
guy today you know and and we did
everything that we could to sort of blur
the line between gay and straight and so
we would do stories that that people
would look at me like hey whoa like what
like a little bit too far out there for
me imagine as a straight guy should I
read it but but the beauty of it is that
it wasn't designed to be a magazine for
everyone and so we we knew who our
audience was and the audience grew very
quickly and the audience responded to
what we were doing and and I would just
often say like hey like if this what
we're doing is like bothering you or met
you know if you feel like it's sort of
putting your masculinity or your idea of
masculinity at risk then the cool you
don't have to you don't have to read it
you know and that would that was fine
but but to kind of blur that line a
little bit and and talk to men who may
have been straight or may have been gay
and and aside from their sexual
preference were had all of the same
interests uh-huh and so this was our guy
right and so but certainly not every guy
there's no question and and perhaps not
even you
that's the irony right don't you don't
you don't cut the figure of like the
details reader which is interesting it
is interesting because at the time when
we've when we relaunched the magazine
with this sort of new approach to making
content I was out doing lots of press
and promoting the the magazine saying
it's for guys like me and meanwhile I'm
in a pair of like converse all-stars and
like ripped up jeans and a t-shirt and a
hoodie you know but I had just been
living in Paris for for almost three
years and had been exposed to this the
kind of European or kind of continental
talk the language absolutely you know I
would look at these guys you know and
and you know that guy's definitely gay
and then like this like you know
beautiful wife would would you know
throw up but like I was like looking at
him in the way he had like his scarf
wrapped around his neck and the way the
suit maybe it was a little more tapered
than the average American guy's suit or
you know listening to him talk about
wine or art or whatever it is I was like
oh wow like this is a really interesting
approach to masculinity but no I
absolutely wasn't wasn't that guy I
think I grew a little bit to become that
guy but I was I was so deeply insecure
with who I was I if I'm being perfectly
honest with you I don't think I know
what kind of guy I was you know I really
I really don't and so it allowed me just
to kind of be a journalist and and react
to where I felt the culture was going
which is what I think we did at details
yeah interesting
well let's take it back let's play a
little game I know you're familiar with
called what it was like what happened
and what it's like now I do this so so
you're from New York you grew up in the
suburbs outside I'm your I grew up in
Baltimore that's right yeah yeah yeah
I'm from DC so we're about there
Bethesda yeah so okay far same thing a
lot of lacrosse I know your brother was
a big look wrong exactly you know
of yeah a lot a lot of star athletes a
lot of you know crab cakes a lot of you
know whales on belts and things like
that exactly did you go to a public high
school I went to private high school
what actually went to a school called
boys lad oh yeah yeah yeah
so there's boys Latin and Gilman that's
exactly right look cry went to land in
okay
probably my high school probably played
lacrosse against you I'm sure you would
not have played against me not me
neither
oh you know I was in partaking in that
world at all but but yeah so yeah I grew
up that's where I grab them right cool
and you end up going to NYU yes yeah so
walk me through just your introduction
to New York man I was in love with New
York from from the moment I went on my
first visit probably when I was 13 or 14
it felt like the perfect place for me
because it seemed like the the ideal
place for someone to just kind of get
lost in a crowd and and that's what I
wanted to do you know you know we talked
about these lacrosse guys and and and if
you have you know listeners out there
that don't know this culture it's a
really interesting culture right I mean
it's but it's akin to football in Texas
or you know basketball in different
parts of the country and soccer now of
course so but it's very at the time
anyway it was like super bro II guys
were like dipping and and this was this
world that I didn't belong to nor really
did I aspire to duck shoes totally dug
shoes or bucks yeah you know and and and
like faded jeans and and and you know
polo shirts you know with the collar up
right it was stuff that that like like
John Hughes and others I think have
documented also incredibly well but it
just wasn't my world and so I when I
first went to New York I was like oh wow
cool like this this this works for me
because I can kind of a
here and and and maybe even kind of
reinvent myself or recreate myself so I
loved it from the moment I got right
what's interesting about your story is
that you would you would suspect or
predict that you know that young person
in New York City gets introduced to
drugs and alcohol pretty rapidly and and
the the love affair and the decline
would begin you know almost immediately
that's not your story that's not my
story you know I I was always in love
with journalism you know so while well
like those sort of like kids there were
the LaCrosse kids I was like the high
school newspaper guy I was like super
ended magic tricks and like studying
magic and stuff like that which I I did
like from from like for as far back as I
can remember and so here I am in New
York and you know the home of every
major media outlet and I was like oh my
god this is gonna be amazing and and I
kind of started working for the for the
NYU school paper and was taking these
journalism courses and we take
journalism courses at NYU at least back
then the professors would bring in you
know big media figures as guest
lecturers and things like that so Dan
Rather who at the time was anchoring the
CBS Evening News came in and spoke and
big newspaper writers and magazine
editors were were the Faculty of of the
NYU journalism program so it was just
absolutely amazing and listen I started
drinking a little bit smoking some pot
and things like that but I didn't I
wasn't going out there were kids that
that got to NYU at 18 that just embraced
the New York City nightlife in ways that
that I did not you know and they would
go to all of these hot clubs and this
and that and you know this was back at a
time when Randy Gerber was just starting
to sort of like open up tons of places
in around New York and they would go to
these places and I I just didn't do that
you know but no my my love affair with
drugs like with so many things in my
life I was a late bloomer
and like loss of my virginity
introduction to two drugs like lots of
good Jewish boy just a good Jewish boy
from the suburbs of Baltimore you know
so the first main gig that you get is at
the Times right no time I was a copy boy
at the New York Times and back when they
had copy boys I don't even know if
that's something that exists there
anymore but it was such an amazing thing
it you know that The Times building has
since moved but they were back in Times
Square on 43rd Street and and they they
actually had press they would actually
printed a portion of the papers right
there and on the ground floor of the
building and trucks would roll out right
from that main floor it was incredibly
romantic you know if you were if you
were a lover of journalism and a student
of journalism this was like the ideal
being there and being in that newsroom
and it was a really kind of amazing
experience for me but I also got I mean
I got reprimanded once for whistling you
know like I'm not like a Whistler but
for some reason I was like you know and
and literally some editor was like hey
no whistling in the newsroom I was like
got it yeah all right but they would
send me down I worked like a 5 p.m. to
11 p.m. shift or maybe even was a little
bit longer than that and they would send
me down to the to the to the press room
to print to pick up first-run copies
uh-huh and and I would bring a stack up
to the newsroom and would like hand them
out to the to the very sort of news
desks and would have ink all over my
hands and my wrists so you talk about
his expression in journalism you know it
being an ink stained wretch and that's
like I literally was so that it was it
was a very cool place to be did you
think you were gonna stay there and work
your way a hundred percent yeah I had
every intention of being a journalist
and in the mold of like David Halberstam
or Woodward and Bernstein you know
absolutely so where does the magazine
things start to come about
you know the magazine thing well listen
you know I couldn't get a job I
graduated NYU with a degree in
journalism or a dual degree also history
but but main main focus on journalism
and and sent out like old school in
envelopes with stamps into into
mailboxes you know tons of resumes and
and just got like a flurry of hey we'll
keep your resume on file letters like
back at me you know including one from
details magazine you know interestingly
and and so I was just desperate for for
a job I wanted to stay in New York but
but time was running out from a from a
financial standpoint and I ended up
getting a job at a company called
Fairchild publications which has changed
a lot over the years but at the time
published Women's Wear Daily and a
number of other papers and magazines
including W Magazine so you say you're a
late bloomer but you it seems like you
didn't waste too much time moving moving
up quickly you know it's interesting I
think like late bloomer with like
everything life experience with
everything related to life experience
with the exception of my career mm-hmm
and so no I I my career moved very
quickly and and it's puzzling to many
myself included but it's
self-deprecating thing is well you know
listen obviously very good at what you
do I mean you know listen you you held
you know these two you know pretty
prominent posts and you held the details
post for 15 years I did I do
yeah like my career my career has been
pretty amazing and and and I feel
blessed I really do and have a lot of
gratitude for that and for the fact that
I was able to hold on to the details job
but but I was a copy boy at the New York
Times I I started then I became a
research editor research assistant or
like fact checker basically at Esquire
magazine which I had always you know
loved and then I got this job working
initially at Fairchild publications for
a publication that's no longer around it
was called The Daily News Record or DNR
which was the male equivalent of Women's
Wear Daily so it covered the like
industry rag for fashion for ferment
yeah you know and and I was a mid wear
sweaters and knitwear editor and I I and
I dove into that with with all the gusto
that any journalist on a new Beach
should but but very shortly after I got
that job really like within six months I
was asked if I wanted to come over to to
Women's Wear Daily for a really coveted
job there on what was the I page you I
he I page and that was their like party
and event coverage so I went literally
from like covering sweater manufacturers
you know and going to conventions of
like knitwear companies to going out and
covering movie premieres and and and
going to all of these events and meeting
and interacting with all these like
extraordinary cultural figures within
the period of like six months and then
how long before they ship you off to
Paris I got shipped off to Paris
probably three years late after that
three or four years after that yeah that
must have been crazy it was in there
going off like fashion shows and you
know hanging out with Karl Lagerfeld and
like all these you know wacky people
from that world it was it was a yeah it
was a very weird time for me because I
that hadn't been my life and that hadn't
been my passion and you weren't like the
kid who was reading you know know those
magazines is not you know but what I was
was it was a was a journalist and was an
editor who really loved storytelling and
and really loved to get people to talk
so even this you know me being on the
other side of this conversation is is
something that I'm not entirely
comfortable doing this is not my comfort
well you got a book out so you guys
absolutely and I'm working through it
but but I oh I really preferred and
still dude
be on the other side to be the one
asking the questions and kind of drawing
the story out so so whether or not I had
an interest in in fashion I look I
didn't even speak French right let's
start there you know they they said hey
we're gonna how would you feel about
going and and and running the Paris
office for W Magazine and I was like
great you know I was 25 yeah
and I was like cool okay what do I need
to do you know well you know how do you
speak any French I was like no I don't
and started to take some lessons which I
didn't really pay very close attention
which is like a huge regret well one of
the one of the things that that was
interesting about that time I read about
you is that you know this this I guess
you could consider the weakness that you
didn't have this inherent like affinity
for this world or this knowledge base
for it but you turn that into a strength
so when you're interviewing these people
instead of talking to them about the
things that everyone's asking them about
you're asking them about their personal
life like oh yeah and and they would
find that refreshing and they have a way
to emotionally connect with the people
that you were covering and engender
their trust and you know maybe get
something a little bit more interesting
out of them and I think that that yeah
that's absolutely true but I also think
that as a journalist that's actually
hugely important to do whatever it is
you're covering you know now look if
you're if you're if you have your you
know covering a political race or you're
covering some community board meeting in
some small town you know you write you
might sort of stick to what you're there
to sort of write about as a you know as
a journalist but if yours you know
having conversations about feature
stories you know you want to make a
connection with your the subject the
person that you're talking to and and
even identify with them if you can and
and you know be empathetic you know
whatever the case may be so I would it
was kind of dropped into this world
where you know these these people these
men and women these fashion designers
these like you know icons have been
talking for their lives and careers
about hemlines and fabrics election and
things like that you know and I would
come in and be like so like what
like tell me about your childhood or
what was what do you have for breakfast
this morning or when was the last time
you just went for a walk around town I
once it was with Karl Lagerfeld the
designer for Chanel and and I was
talking I was like when was the last
time we just walked around Paris you
know and he's like well I my dear boy
you know I cannot walk around Paris you
know and and and they you right because
he's there was like a walking caricature
of himself right with the ponytail and
the fan and all of that but but the guy
does he literally always have the fan
you know I spend a lot of time with him
idea and I honestly don't know if I ever
saw a fan hmm I may have seen one like
resting on a table somewhere but it was
certainly not like some some some prop
okay so I I was able to to kind of find
a way in and develop relationships with
these people and and and and cover them
in in ways that that were maybe a little
bit different right you know so you get
the call for details mm yeah yeah I got
the call for details in 2000 and and you
know details had been around for many
years details was it was a really
amazing magazine was founded in the 80s
bye-bye you know brilliant woman named
Annie Flanders and and it was very you
know sort of downtown and plugged into
into the club scene and and and a whole
level of the culture that like just
wasn't even on my radar and it was
ultimately purchased by by Conde Nast
sign Newhouse who ran it for many years
Conde Nast magazines which publishes
vogue and The New Yorker and Vanity Fair
and all that and and then it had a
couple it had James Truman was a great
editor there and it had become they had
really sort of built it up but as they
were building it up like I said before
the whole landscape regarding men's
magazines specifically was was shifting
into something that was kind of seeping
into our culture from
England which were these magazines that
were rooted more toward like the sort of
lad culture right now beer and babes and
Assam was really the kind of touchstone
of almost maximum maximum was the holy
grail of that and and then it there were
like a number of competitors sort of
started to crop up to try to sort of
grab their share of that business
because maximum just like exploded onto
the culture and and in ways that men's
magazines had never even really seen
before and so at Conde Nast they tried
to turn details into a magazine like
that they actually hired the former
editor-in-chief of Maxim a guy named
Mark Golan to come in and kind of Maxima
fie details and that just didn't work
and ultimately it really didn't even fit
in with the sort of broader kind of
corporate Conde Nast identity of luxury
and sophistication and culture you know
these are the people that you know did
Conde Nast Traveler and The New Yorker
and then all of a sudden they were
trying to do this like hey how do we
compete in this world of men's magazines
and that didn't work so they shut it
down and they were gonna relaunch it and
they asked me if I wanted to be the
editor-in-chief that that right so the
idea being rather than try to compete in
that world to counter-program against it
and find a niche with a different
audience right I mean let's find some
white space here you know anyone that
that has any kind of branding you know
you don't you don't want to just jump
into a crowded market and do the same
thing that the market leaders are doing
right you can do that and and we saw
that with people trying to imitate Maxim
but but it's certainly smarter to to try
to find a different path and and or to
maybe reach an audience that that feels
underserved by the kind of current
constellation of magazines yeah and so
that's that's that's what we ended up
doing so much of the job seems to be
having your finger on the
the pulse of like what's cool now like
you have to really be dialed in to lower
Manhattan right and like what is
actually happening that like the rest of
America isn't aware of that's kind of
percolating in those subcultures right
it it was finding the trend before it
was a trend uh-huh it was it was being
you know just early enough on an idea
and then you know sharing that with your
audience you know you could be too early
and and it would go nowhere and then if
you were late everyone had already
served seen the idea so it was just kind
of trying to to get it at the exact
moment when it was just before it became
a thing and and hoping actually that you
were a story on it is what helped make
it a thing yeah you know so then your
job is to find the people because I mean
you're if you're like listening to Rick
Springfield and you're like you don't
seem like the right guy but but I would
take I would imagine your talent is like
knowing who those people are and
recruiting them to be part of this team
I think taste in music is acai and I'm
just using that as an example but that's
a good example for Rick Springfield man
Jesse's girl listen you're in your Lord
nothing but love it when if Jesse girl
comes on tell me you don't just take a
moment it's all yeah there alone
you know turn that up tiny a little bit
all right
I'll give you that all right I think
even Rick Springfield would say yeah
it's probably not cool yeah but a lot of
love for you Rick yes III think I was
able to to put together a team of people
that could find those things of like
cool hunters and people that that that
understood the culture and then and and
could could see what was coming and were
tapped in in really important ways in
lots of different categories so you know
food you know bar culture music
certainly entertainment
Travel also fashion obviously all sorts
of things and then they would come to me
and say hey this is this is what's kind
of percolating out there and I think my
strength was the ability to say okay
this is a story this isn't a story where
hey how do we find a way into this story
you know what what is this what what
makes sense here for our reader based
upon what you're telling me so you're
right like I was never the guy that was
the cool hunter I was never cool period
and so but I I had the ability to say
hey that's cool
and so that that's what that's what made
me able to do my job but know if you
dropped me in lower man listen I know
people we've all grown up with people
that will you put them anywhere
we still I still know people today I'm
48 that like you kind of put them
anywhere and they find it they find it
and all of a sudden they know the great
the coolest people I just got invited to
this one I this one I was never that guy
but I was able to find those people and
and in turn find some pretty interesting
story huh but you would still have to I
mean I remember reading details when
Truman was the editor and there's always
I mean this is a thing with these kind
of magazines there's you know you see
Graydon Carter doing this you know when
he was editing very fair but like that
the beautiful photo of the editor and
then the letter the beginning right and
an editor always looks super cool and so
you know get up or whatever and then you
have to write this thing about what's
going to be in the issue I kind of
synopsize like what's happening right
now
with that was that challenging for you
like I would imagine you did that right
I did they dress you up and know I wrote
the letter but there was never a photo
there's never a photo you never a photo
of me on that page I was I I you know
there's we go back to like the sort of
insecurities theme I ever liked being
photographed this isn't being recorded
is it I was never comfortable in front
of a camera and I hated hated
being at an event and having someone say
hey let's get your picture and that's
your job I mean you talk about this in
the book just being you going to all of
these crazy events that most people you
know a lot of people would kill to be
able to attend and you're a Wallflower
and there you got publicist yanking on
you take a picture with this person and
that person and you just not want him to
do it right and and I think like I will
I'll try to sort of like draw out the
distinction between being a wallflower
and not wanting to have my photo taken I
could could maneuver around the room I
was I really have always enjoyed talking
to people and so and I could do that
with relative ease it was the and I
write about this in the book you're
right we're like I would be at some
event that I was hosting for like some
Hollywood celebrity and they would be
like oh hey Dan let's get a picture of
you and so-and-so and it would literally
be the superhero from the superhero
movie and I would have to stand there
with him and as I write in the book I
always felt like the before photo in
like some plastic surgeon's office you
know next to this like chiseled guy with
like this Chiclets smile and like abs
that you could see through a suit and
like I was kind of like just never
really feeling it so the beauty of being
the editor-in-chief of the magazine was
that when it came to that letter from
the editor that had to go in every issue
I could just say hey we're not gonna put
a photo of me on this page and that just
became the no huh cuz you were the boss
cuz I was the boss right all right well
let's get to the drugs yeah it all
starts with a cartwheel it does man I
you know I you know have done lots of
stupid things in my life and and and I I
detail many of them actually in my book
but perhaps the stupidest and and maybe
the the the one if not even maybe I
think the one thing that actually I
think forever changed the course of my
life was the cartwheel you know and men
have done so many dumb [ __ ] things
over the years to impress
women i mean countless in my case it was
a cartwheel and and so here i was i was
in my early 20s I was I was working
still at at Women's Wear Daily covering
these parties and and things like that
movie premieres and stuff like that and
I was meeting up with a couple of
friends and we were in the lobby of an
office building in lower Manhattan and
this friend came off the elevator one of
the guy that I that me and another
friend were there to meet and was with
three or four young women and was
introducing us and said hey so-and-so
just got a job promotion and I was like
oh that's amazing but can she do this
and I attempted a cartwheel which it's
important to note I had never done
before uh-huh and and and and it looked
as if I had never done one before
because I came crashing down on the
floor and and hurt my back so but this
was like me like seeking attention this
is me like this is my this is like a
theme throughout my my entire life
really was like where am I where am I
getting validation from here you know
and and how am I getting eyes on me and
in this instance it was gonna be a
cartwheel and I did it and I hurt my
back and I went to see a doctor probably
a day or two later and was prescribed
vicodin and you know that's how the seed
was planted for me you know and and took
this vikon and ultimately had back
surgery two back surgeries actually on
my lower back and and was essentially
off to the races you know with opiates
was it that thing where the first time
you took it you just knew you know it
was probably it wasn't until the third
or fourth time which was still within a
matter of a couple days of taking it
well initially if the pain is severe
enough right it mutes any kind of high
that you're gonna explain exactly so I
think when I first took it it did
exactly what it was
scribe to do which was mellow out the
whatever pain I was feeling but it was
only really a day or two later that I
realized oh wow this is this is how I
want to feel you know and you just you
saw me like I just took a deep breath
answer to every question I ever had you
know or well it's solution to every
problem I didn't know that I had it's
like oh this is what I've been looking
for this is this is gonna make me feel
like me this is what I need like I'm
home and and it was the beginning of at
least what I thought was like really
important love affair from being honest
you know
and it happened incredibly quickly well
the thing that gets a couple
observations I mean the first of all the
thing that gets missed in stories like
this often is the love affair aspect of
it like it does work for a period of
time and serving some need right and
it's fascinating how people find their
way I mean not everybody but a lot of
people like find their way to the the
drug that does something that feels like
it's you know it's that missing puzzle
piece in their life and that and it was
for me and so you know I I had grown up
in Baltimore I was the younger brother
of like one of the town stars you know
like a golden boy in town my brother
Jeff and whom I loved dearly and he was
the captain of the lacrosse team which
in that kind of like lacrosse obsessed
environment was like icon status right
he was he went to Cornell he was you
know on his way to the Ivy League
he was great looking and had tons of
girlfriends and I was the sort of the
little brother who like did magic tricks
in the basement and and wasn't any of
those things
and so and this takes me to the the car
wheel even you know like it's just like
I was like seeking something you know
and I just had never found it
and and so with the cartwheel it was
seeking validation or appreciation or
trying to get a laugh or trying to get a
girlfriend and mean who the hell there's
a cartwheel to get a girlfriend but or a
date even not even a girlfriend but
that's sort of where I was so by the by
the time I
I took these vicodin I I was I was like
I was a seeker you know and I was
searching for something and it was that
missing piece for me and it was amazing
I I don't want to to glamorize you know
any kind of drug use if I'm being honest
you know but but in that moment it it
was like being enveloped by it just be
like being like embraced in a way that I
had never been embraced a warm blanket
it's the warm blanket as I described
exactly it was like being just wrapped
in a warm blanket and and it was like oh
this is this is how I should feel hmm
and not prior to that like no real you
know indicia that you have this inner
addict inside of you like no no you know
issues with alcohol or like that I'm
just like really interesting no none
whatsoever you know I mean listen I
partook I you know I mean I went to
college and I drank and like I said I
smoked pot and and I had like but had a
healthy you know relationship with that
stuff you know and nothing in nothing
that would have indicated in any way
that I should probably steer clear of
any of this uh-huh until the vicodin
came into my life I was listening to
your conversation with dr. Drew the
other day and he was he was like
befuddled and confused by this until you
until you mentioned that you were Jewish
and it was like this light bulb goes off
and it like he's searching for her like
he's trying to he's trying to do the
math in his head about how this works
and that was a really interesting part
of that conversation was was yeah when
he was trying to get to the bottom of
any childhood trauma any dad in alcohol
and
no no no no yeah yeah he's like what you
know you know what's your ethnicity you
know or what's your sort of like we're
like aha make up and I was like ah
you're askin Aussie Jew he's like
absolutely there it is you know and I
was like what I'd never heard that
before I'd never heard that either and
and I have like a huge amount of respect
for dr. drew but I you know in that
moment I was like what
I mean basically for people that are
listening or watching what he said was
that there's something specific to
Ashkenazi Jews that that have like this
what did he say exactly something about
like later in life addiction with
opioids specifically or something about
that that lineage of humanity that
Cotton's onto that in a specific way
that's correct
and and and that's precisely what he
said and and and now for all the Jewish
moms that may be out there listening to
this you know don't don't lock don't
lock your children up quite yet you know
but that's this is this belief that that
that he has and and and I can't speak to
it but but because surely he knows what
he's talking about but I just can't
speak to it but he yeah light bulb went
off and and so that that was that was it
for me I I and so let's say that's true
okay you know these these pills came
into my life and and boom here right
here I am right you know and this
quickly progresses you know you get up
to like 60 pills a day and it becomes
your primary occupation trying to source
and fill these scripts and make sure
that your stash never runs out yeah
that's like reading this and listening
to you talk about it you know I I relate
to that
like obsession but it also just reminds
me how exhausting it is it's like the
amount of effort that went into making
sure that you always had what you needed
I mean it's it's just it's not a
preoccupation it is the predominant
thing that lives in breeze inside you 24
hours a day I had never worked hard
at anything in my life before that point
I had I had never been as committed to
anything in my life before that point
maintaining a supply of these pills was
really my only focus and I had a big job
at details at this point and and family
and friends and and you know trying to
like manage relationships and things
like that but this was really the only
thing that I paid any true-true
attention to you know which is
fascinating in and of itself right
because here I was I was running this
magazine and and and but this was really
all I cared about and so when you get up
to as I did 60 vicodin a day I
ultimately switched over to another drug
that that the numbers came down the it's
called Roxy yeah Roxy Kota like twice
the dosage it was twice the dosage but
without the tylenol so like with I was
taking extra strains vicodin I was
essentially taking so I was taking let's
say 60 day I would take two just to
break it down I would take and and by
the way not immediately I worked my way
down to his numbers right I didn't just
dive in you know you know what 60 seems
like a good number I ultimately got to
15 at a time and I was doing it about
four times a day and so the the the the
active ingredients of an extra-strength
vicodin are hydrocodone which is the you
know the codeine based sort of you know
analgesic painkiller an opiate opiate
portion of it and acetaminophen or you
know which is which is tylenol right and
so I was taking in addition to all of
the opiates I was essentially taking a
small bottle of extra Sentinal a day
right four years right and we all know
the dangers of acetaminophen but that
was another thing that dr. drew talked
about that he still doesn't see liver
toxicity in people that are taking vikon
it at that dosage level because the
liver
figures out a way to process all of this
and keep you from dying correct and it's
amazing and when I got sober and and
went to my doctor he was like we need to
take a look at your liver right you know
like first and foremost which which was
fine you know yeah the body has a way of
and you have way of sort of like making
it work for addicts and and and the
addiction is super crazy powerful I'm of
the belief that like it's quite possible
that the addiction also just sort of
finds a way Atalaya like keep letting
allowing you to feed it you know and
that may sound bizarre but that's sort
of like my view of it but but when you
need that many pills it's really hard to
get them and so so it does take a lot of
energy and I put a ton of energy into it
and was quite artful about it and you
know I think you know like I you know
addicts are brilliant liars unbelievable
yeah like that was one thing Jeff said
said said ask ask ask Dan if he thinks
he's the best liar in the world right we
we are masterful liars and and and and
then certainly like a like you know like
the really close like first cousin of
that is great con artists you know and
so I would go into these doctors offices
and I was doctor shopping I was seeing
probably four or five different doctors
at a time and and filling different
prescriptions in different parts of town
and I would put on quite a performance
for them on each visit and and and over
time the the performances became more
and more elaborate because suspicions
yeah you know elaborate or / comedic and
transparent and I suspect it was a
different I I would imagine it's harder
now is everything is happening and the
crisis that you know our culture is
weathering at the moment but at the time
and this was another interesting thing
that came up with you and dr. drew this
was the heyday of the pain management
clinics and this idea that you know
opioids were
you know the solution and this white hat
you know mentality and the litigious
nature of our our healthcare system such
that you know no doctor wants to get
sued for denying yeah like saying while
he was bullshitting me and then finding
out he was wrong so there was just a an
epidemic of oversubscription there was
and and this is where I think like the
the conversation with dr. drew let's get
into it because I have thoughts on this
too yeah I have a sense of what you
wanted to say it didn't say I and it got
interesting and it took an unexpected
turn when Drew said to me he was he
became an apologist for the
pharmaceutical industry in a certain way
it may be in a certain way he did he was
very dismissive of the the complicity
like yes what would he said and I was
not stung but I was taking it back and I
don't want to misrepresent what he said
and let me just say for the record too
like I I had got crazy respect for
doctor yeah but he put it all on the
medical community the doctors that were
writing the prescriptions and and he was
like no no no it's all the doctors is
all the doctors and again I I don't want
to misrepresent him surely you know I
think anyone knows that the
pharmaceutical companies here were
complicit also but but I was about to go
down this road with him where I was
gonna say something to the effect of
listen these pharmaceutical companies
have spent hundreds of millions of
dollars in marketing to to do a number
of different things and I'm going to
circle back to them to the point where
you just were but but to do a number of
different things one of those things I
think quite simply was to falsely
minimize the risk of addiction with
respect to opiates right right and
that's one thing to agreed with right
these people don't understand addiction
right you know but they have also spent
hundreds of millions of dollars helping
convince doctors that if this is in my
opinion helping convince doc
that they were ignoring patients pain
and that there were broader uses for
drugs like this and that pain is to be
taken seriously and this is the sort of
like evil genius of of these companies
you know companies like Purdue and
others that were you know teaching
quote/unquote teaching or educating
doctors that you're ignoring patients
pain that pain is real and that you have
to trust and believe patients when they
come to you and for a drug addict like
me and for a world-class liar like me I
was able to manipulate the [ __ ] out of
that because I could go in in a suit and
tie and I could go in limping and dry
like my performance was fairly or and
right you're talking about like you you
would get out of the cabin limp into the
doctor's office and limp out just in
case
rice happen to see you or whatever I
maintain the ruse I would live down the
street I would start my my performance a
block or two away from the doctor's
office in the event that someone that
worked in that office may have been out
running out to grab a coffee or running
an errand or something like that I would
you know I couldn't have them see me not
in character so it would start the
second I climbed out of the subway or
out of a taxi and I would I would limp
down the street but I wouldn't just limp
down the street I would I would stop and
like and like wince I would lean against
like you know a fire hydrant or whatever
it was in and catch my breath like I
really committed to this performance but
but but to go back to dr. Drew he he
said you know ya know it's all these
doctors all the doctors all the doctors
all the doctors I actually came
management the pain management doctors
write that and and and and listen it
says surely he knows far more about this
than I do I know based on my experiences
what happened to me and and I actually
believe that these doctors were
genuinely interested and genuinely
you know and deeply in some instances
concerned about the symptoms that I was
presenting and and I can't fault them
for not being for not calling [ __ ]
on me you know like the performances
were we're pretty oscar-worthy for a
time you know there really were and so
but yeah so we so here I am sitting and
talking to Drew and we just sort of have
we had this conversation and I just was
surprised that that it went that way
well certainly there is a you know an
awareness level in the c-suite of these
pharmaceutical companies that you know
look they know they're selling an insane
amount of these pills these medications
are going out like the level of you know
pain versus the prescription level you
know to anybody who would kind of you
know evaluate that spreadsheet would
look out of whack right like clearly
people are abusing these drugs well not
only that but but they they quite
successfully managed to to convince
doctors that if you know kit you know if
some college baseball player breaks his
arm oh this is good for that too like
initially these drugs were were were
most frequently prescribed for you
end-of-life care
cancer patients in just like
excruciating agonizing pain victims of
accidents and things like that
and they these the people in these C
Suites at these pharmaceutical companies
I think seized on an opportunity to to
say okay hey listen there's like we're
under like there's there's there's more
market here for us you know because
there are lots of people that are having
teeth pulled and breaking bones and and
injuring themselves by doing cartwheels
and and things like that that that we
are that we should be tapping into
mmm-hmm what's what's interesting about
your case is that you would think that
somebody of your kind of privilege and
staff
you hear these stories I don't know
whether they're apocryphal or not of you
know people who are you know have that
kind of level of access have their you
know their their their special doctor
who's you know ethically compromised
who's just more than willing to you know
write all kinds of crazy scripts for you
know cash under the table but you're
playing the shell game with you know
these doctors that are you know not
those people right like you're just
trying to get these scripts written I am
as much as possible because that was
that was the least initially that's
that's what I was doing but but I I
would always I always felt like a
pretender I was always pretending and
the magic the idea of like creating an
illusion the idea of deception is is
something that I can now all these years
later look back and say oh like my love
and interest in magic and card tricks
and coin tricks and all those magic
books that I pour it over and all those
you know video tapes that I bought and
like basically wore out the VCR playing
and watching learning and studying magic
really this is your ultimate opportunity
this would apply all that this was the
Grandmaster Sheree you know realize and
and and and I and I owned it you know
and and and and worked to perfect it you
know I would go into these pain
management specialists offices and I
would would walk into the waiting room
and I would see the pain patients the
real pain patients sitting there people
like with just you know no color in
their faces people that that you know
took all the energy that they probably
could muster just to like get from home
to the doctor's office to you know and I
would I would look at their expressions
or the way they walked or the way that
they would like lower themselves into
the chair in the waiting room and and I
would sponge off of that I would would
make my stick better from from watching
these people you know like a method
acting
ouch totally my favorite of all your
roses is it was when you would create
these elaborate overseas itinerary I'm
gonna be in Australia for 30 days and
you would reserve airline tickets and
printout you'd have your assistant
printed I would show up at the
pharmacist with my passport in hand yeah
so I would you know what I was running
out I was running out of pills and I was
running out of doctors to get pill you
need when you're taking 60 a day you're
you're always running out you're right
you're right and so it was it was a
constant search for pills it's all I all
I cared about and so I would I would
start going back to doctors that had
prescribed me you know 300 pills to two
weeks ago I would go back to them after
two weeks when they wrote me a
prescription for a month
and I would start having to get creative
in that respect also you can't go into
these doctors and say I lost my pills
that's just like that they weren't gonna
swallow but I would go in and I would
use my job at Details magazine to sort
of help you know legitimize this and I
would say hey like it's the worst
possible timing but I'm going off on
like a world tour too like and I would
make up just ridiculous [ __ ] I'm going
to a textile mill in Italy to see how
you know cashmere is made and then right
from there I'm going to this like
leather moccasin Factory to see how
their hand-sewn and then I'm going over
to Australia to do this and and here
I've brought the itinerary you know and
I would have an anticipation of this
meeting my assistant at the magazine
make up a travel itinerary and I would
just say hey can you put together a
travel itinerary start me in Milan then
take me to like Sicily and then from
Sicily to Rome and then for
Rome to Sydney and and my assistant
would look at me like what on earth like
oh you know I just I'm just curious
you know I'm you know I doubt I'm gonna
do this trip but just go ahead and and
call the travel agent and put together
the itinerary and let's price it out and
then she would print out an itinerary
for me and I big okay yeah let's not go
ahead and book it but I would have this
this sheet in my hand and I would go see
the doctor's one after the next it would
be like the same thing like listen my
back's been killing me so it's the worst
possible timing but I just need to do
this maybe I should even probably just
quit my job because you know it's it's
it's sort of untenable and and and I I'm
thinking about and I would just go into
this like I would go off on this like
improv routine and and like limping and
clutching and wincing and and and and
groaning in pain where I felt no pain by
the way you know and there's no physical
outward indicia that you're loaded like
your are your pupils pinned are you
clammy like no no because or at least
not that I was was aware of and
nothing's there were there were no
obvious tells and and I wouldn't go into
these doctors offices load it up and hi
you know I was able to sort of be I
would try to be anyway smart about the
timing of what I refer to in the book is
my feedings taking pills were my
feedings and I was feeding this beast of
this addiction and so I would time my
feedings around you know what I deemed
to be important meetings not just
meetings with doctors but meetings with
my boss or even a phone call with my mom
or whatever the case was you know
because more and more people were
starting to look at me a little
strangely I'm starting to ask hey like
what's wrong with you you know right
like that was like a refrain for me from
these years like hey what's wrong with
you were like that's not normal yeah
like those two things hearing the word
normal like it's still like a trigger
trigger from you know because I wasn't
normal you know and but yeah I would go
I would go to great lengths to convince
these doctors that that I was like
legitimate
in need of a new prescription and just
keeping track of when you talk to that
doctor the last time and you know how
much time it allowed by keeping all your
stories he's actually quite simple book
like thanks like thanks to like a
spreadsheet or so the pill bottles have
labels with dates on them and I could
say okay I got this filled that which
means I saw the doctor that same day I
didn't sit on prescriptions and I would
get them filled immediately and I could
and I would start to I would use those
as like my road map basically uh-huh
then you have this the pink the pink you
know bathroom situation I like there
would I would the the the visits to the
doctor's office just weren't enough they
really weren't when this when this and
let me say also that like I can sort of
talk about this now with some measure of
excitement or even like humor you know
but this is this is a dark and awful
place to be I mean it really is and and
and and anyone that that has struggled
with or is actively you know dealing
with this addiction or has someone in
their life that is actively dealing with
this issue and let's be honest
like a lot of people that's a lot of
people right this touches a lot of
people you don't have to go too far you
know in your kind of world and your own
orbit to find someone that is dealing
with this in some way but but but any
you know as I wrote this book I had a
little bit of distance from it I was
able to look back on some of these
experiences and and and find also some
some moments of levity there the moment
of the this pink gown was a really
interesting time because I I would run
out of doctors that I could call because
you start to know who's gonna give them
up and who's not you know and
I got one more with this guy who's gonna
be done with me totally like I can
probably write I'm gonna try this guy
but they're probably not gonna give me
an appointment or write or they'll take
care of me one more time and then I'm
like dead to them you know and you know
because they would say okay I'll give
you these pills but you know I really
think you need to start physical therapy
or I want to start doing certain like
nerve block injections like I didn't
want any of that [ __ ] I just wanted the
pills so I needed to start to find
different ways to get them and sometimes
when I was really bad cuz let's let's
just take a second and talk about what
happens when you stop taking the pill
yeah so when you run out it is
absolutely brutal as a perfect word it's
just it's brutal
you know it's hell on earth and and the
the acute physical symptoms of opiate
withdrawal are such that you your body
you know because your body needs them
your body is craving them your brain it
has has has gotten accustomed to having
this chemical there and and and and your
body just absolutely starts to demand
them when you run out of them and so and
it lets you know that it's not happy at
loud and clear like yeah like in an
unmistakable way and so you start to
feel rundown you start to have hot
flashes you start sweating and then all
of a sudden you're freezing you can get
headaches use nausea and diarrhea and
brain doesn't work either you can't you
can't focus create a cohesive thought
you can't and it's just absolutely
miserable and any depiction of opiate
withdrawal which includes heroin that
you've seen in a movie is very accurate
you know it's you're you're you're
shivering you're shaking you're
miserable your whole body aches you
can't think you can't focus and and it
doesn't just come and go it sticks with
you and so I would run out of pills all
the time and I would go through
withdrawal all the time and I would go
to the emergency room that that was near
where I lived in New York City at the
time st. Vincent's it's no longer there
it's now like ridiculously priced condos
but I would go to the emergency room and
and I would walk in and and so the like
first time I went I had been at an event
that evening a gala where I was wearing
a tuxedo and and the symptoms of
withdrawal were kicking in while I was
at this gala and I eventually left and
went home
peeled off my tuxedo and just basically
got into bed and and like waited for
this to happen which was awful the the
anxiety the the fear of it coming was
was equally as powerful as the actual
withdrawal it's symptoms itself you know
just this sort of buildup of anxiety and
terror you know I'm gonna describe it in
the book as as like a scene from a
horror movie where like you're hiding
and like this sort of killer is like you
know the killers in the room right and
you're under the bed or you're in the
closet and you see feet walk by or like
a shadow or silhouette of something and
you just know it's about to come and it
does you know and like the you get
yanked out from underneath the bed or
the closet door flies open and like
you're toast and that's what that's what
I felt this like deep panic of like oh
my god it's coming it's coming it's
gonna be unrelenting it is it's just
awful so this night of this gala I was
like you know screw this I'm gonna go to
the emergency room and I actually at
like 2:00 or 3:00 in the morning put the
tuxedo back on and went into an
emergency room because I I felt that I
wouldn't I wouldn't present as just like
a junkie you know looking like truly
like itching like and quite literally
for a fix if I had this tuxedo you know
and that like somehow you know this
would make my experience there easier
and walk into the emergency room and the
triage nurses
like they've seen it all you know like
in New York City emergency room at like
3:00 in the morning and but I I managed
to kind of get in and I was in this sort
of part of the emergency room and they
had given me this blue gown this blue
paper gown to put on and I put my tuxedo
in a in a bag that they had given me to
hold my stuff and I'm sitting across
from this woman pretty much the same
distance that I am from you now so just
a few feet and and she was in a pink
paper gown to my blue paper gown and we
were in an incredibly well-lit room and
she was there was a stack she was next
to the counter that had a sink and a
stack of individually wrapped alcohol
wipes and probably some cotton balls and
tongue depressors and like that nyhammer
and she was staring at me and she was
naked under her gown and I know this
because she was sort of exposing herself
to me and she was taking one at a time
these alcohol wipes she would tear them
open take one out wipe it all over her
face drop it to the floor take another
one while keeping eye contact with me
was fascinating and I eventually get led
out of that room and in to see a doctor
and part of my whole shtick when I was
talking to doctors was to appear as
normal as possible and part of my whole
shtick in life as we talked about with
me getting dropped into the world of
journalism of fashion journaling was was
engaging with people immediately you
know and so so I would engage this
doctor I did in this instance in the
emergency room I'm talking to this
doctor it's the middle of the night he's
got to be exhausted and I'm like wow
it's a you know it's like the Star Wars
Cantina out there in the waiting room as
you and I were finally thankfully I can
connect with like a normal person
because you know it's it's it's pretty
weird out there man and and I'm talking
to him I start telling him about this
this this woman that I was sitting
across from who was exposing herself to
me and and wiping these these alcohol
you know swabs all over her face and he
said to me really without even kind of
looking up you know like what color
gallon was she wearing was it pink
and I was like like how do you know that
and he's like what we give the people
that we have psychiatric concerns about
pink gowns so that everyone knows that
when they see someone in a pink gown
keep your eye on them and make sure that
they aren't a risk to themselves or
other patients or don't like just sort
of behave in a way that would generally
be be you know described as crazy and I
was like oh wow that's interesting I get
a prescription from this guy um I go
about my business not four or five
months later I'm back in the emergency
room I'm not wearing a tuxedo this time
and and the the the symptoms of
withdrawal are particularly powerful and
I'm had taken some other things to try
to help tamp them down valium and things
like that and it was the middle of the
night and I was found my way to the to
the hospital I just was desperate I just
couldn't go through withdrawal you know
yet again and and I go up to the window
the triage nurse and I explained you
know tried to sort of stay true to my
script you know but must have delivered
a subpar performance you know because
she was like it's gonna be a few minutes
and and I eventually get led into to a
room and and there's like an intake
nurse taking my blood pressure and
things like that and I starting to them
sweating and I think my voice was
probably quivering but I'm still trying
to stick true to stay to my sort of
speech spiel and I'm like how long will
this be because I you know have early
meetings tomorrow I don't know if I've
mentioned this but I'm the I'm the
editor in chief of details magazine
that's a major national magazine by the
way and I have lots of important things
in front of me and and this is just like
a burden for me and she's like you're
gonna be here definitely for a little
while you know so why don't you go ahead
and change out of your clothes and put
this on and she handed me a pink paper
gown yeah
but here's the thing did you bust a move
out of that sure did yeah I got right
outta your yeah you're one step away
from getting locked up yeah I got right
out of there
you know I my story has lots of moments
like that though there were there were
there were it is funny but it is you
know it's it's sad and it's pathetic and
it's you know it just speaks to the
places that something like this will
take you it does it take it speaks to
the depth depths that this will take you
and and for me you know I've been asked
as I'm as I'm sort of now tanned about
talking about my book you know like hey
man like what was your what's your
bottom you know and that's that's a
question that that people in recovery
will ask other people in recovery and
that's a question that people want to
know like man what was your breaking
point like what what got you to sobriety
and it is most often a bottom of some
kind you know I lost my job I had a
horrible car accident nearly killed
someone did kill someone like awful
horrible things that that happened when
people you know abuse alcohol and drugs
I didn't have one bottom I I feel like I
just had like a series of progressively
demoralizing situations crass act up
that just stacked that stacked up you
know and and and and this was just this
was just one of them you know but but I
think my point is that I would wake up
the next day after having like what
should have been a moment of clarity
like hey man wow like this this is
getting really bad you know and and
people are starting to be on to you here
and or you know like you're gonna die
you know and I would say that to myself
all the time like I would I would I got
to a point where I was at night time
were like my biggest highs I would take
the most pills at night because I would
could think the big feeding the big
feeding exactly I could I could really
just kind of Zonk myself out you know
and I would take you know 15 pills let's
say and then be like you know I'm gonna
like a couple more on top of that just
to like really numb myself out but this
might kill me but I I would take them
anyway and and it's not that I wanted to
die because I don't think I wanted to
die I was prepared to die though for
that high right it was just something I
was prepared to do and and but I would
wake up the next morning from these
moments and I would start all over again
you know I wasn't and this is the thing
you know and there are probably a lot of
people in recovery that will be like you
know yeah like you're not you're not
ready until you're ready yeah you know
and and it's hard to to me even when you
think you're ready your problem you may
still not be ready I mean you have this
story about you you go through the full
detox at your mom's right and then
basically shortly thereafter cop right
away I do I do not not not planning to
but that's just that's the way it works
yes that from me that was right in that
and it's a really powerful addiction
right so I went down to my mom's house
in Baltimore and and what what did it
for me ultimately I was ready I just
couldn't stop I absolutely couldn't stop
you know I knew I needed to stop I
acknowledge that I was a drug addict I
knew that I was gonna probably die if I
didn't stop I had been OD'ing so I would
had stopped breathing a number of number
of times in the middle of the night
there's a write about in the book of a
girlfriend like waking up literally with
someone like a girlfriend on top of me
like basically banging on my chest like
freaking out because I wasn't breathing
later when I was married my wife would
say you know in the morning like well
you were like gasping for air in the
middle of the night you know almost like
you're holding your breath like you know
what's what's going on
you know and I'm like I don't know maybe
it's sleep apnea or something like that
it's crazy how long you got away with it
in your marriage it's extraordinary how
long I got away with it in my marriage
and and it's also you know if we're
being really honest you know it's
extraordinary what I put
through yeah and and and I guess you're
never really present and there's no true
intimacy as long as you know that exists
between you
that's correct there's like a wall in
between us and there was just there was
something that was more important there
was something I loved more mm-hmm
you know and that was that was these
drugs and and and it's hard for me to
say this now like I feel it like I
didn't feel like you know like emotions
stirring up around this you know but
that's just the truth like I was I
wasn't present for anyone or anything in
my life
other than this addiction the only thing
that I cared about and feeding it and so
the the people that are around addicts
the people that are in the lives of
addicts certainly moms and dads and
siblings but also spouses and partners
and colleagues all of those things
really are just victims of this
addiction also they suffer tremendously
at the hands of this addiction also yeah
and and and the addict is blind to that
until it's way to loot Lee the addict
does not see it worse the addict will
try to turn it and Gaslight and will try
to of course I've got to protect that
above everything exactly so I would I
would try to make anyone that like would
would start to question my behavior I
would do everything in my power to make
it seem like to actually make it seem
like like you owe me an apology for
suggesting that like what's wrong with
you or why are you being paranoid or
whatever it is you know and the great
lie of course I mean the during the
romance period there's this sense that
you're hyper productive and you're able
to like you know perform at a higher
level and like this is what I need in
order to do this crazy job that I have
right and it's only over time that you
realize that that's all a lot that's all
[ __ ] and right there is a little bit
of a narrative out there around your
story in your book that you are this
high functioning addict tonight I guess
you know I I don't believe I understand
that but like yeah it's not true right I
be true beauty Kannada you become this
absentee editor
you're like working from home or you're
coming up with reasons not to come into
the office shit's going haywire there's
you know crises that are happening that
are widely publicized about things that
are happening at the magazine and this
this you know sense that you become this
very mercurial person right who's prone
to these outbursts and unpredictable and
it was more of a an air of mystery than
anything else but I think I think that
that's an amazing point I'm really glad
you brought that up it's actually really
sort of like astute point to make like
if I wasn't high functioning and I've
been and and that is part of this sort
of thing that's out there now about this
book that I was this high functioning
addict I I wasn't I was an addict hiding
in plain sight and there are a lot of
addicts hiding in plain sight it's like
what was that story in The New York
Times about the Silicon Valley executive
and the the wife who didn't know and she
found him dead like I think they were
divorced but then she found him dead in
his place and all the files everywhere
exactly yeah yeah yeah and I know her
and and Eileen and she's she's written a
terrific terrific book and about her
experience smash that's a smacked
smacked right yeah and or these I'm
pretty sure and and so so look I I
wasn't high functioning you may I may
have appeared to be and I and I didn't
try to portray it that way in the book
in fact I think I portray it quite
honestly I think just people in a
perfunctory way like oh he was able to
hold this job for right seven years or
whatever right you know well you know
while under the influence and I was and
so that you right that leads people to
then say you must have been a high
functioning addict I was and I was an
absentee editor I was plugged in you
know when I needed to be and and was was
there at the ideation stage of things
because that was always my strength
finding the story what's the way in here
what's the best way for us to tell this
story even high I was able to do that
but I was not there in any meaningful
way
and and had it not been for an
extraordinary team of editors and
writers and and everyone that's around
helping to sort of produce a magazine
it just it wouldn't have gotten
published right the other narrative
that's emerged from your book which I
imagine is probably comes as somewhat of
a surprise to you is that now it's
become this referendum on corporate
responsibility and you know what
actually was going on at Conde Nast
during this time yes and I don't care
for that narrative too much I'm not
paying that much attention to it
but I know that it's there and I think
listen people are entitled to have
whatever reaction they want to to the to
the book I think what I'm learning is
that there are certain media people that
that their reaction is and then I want
to circle back to getting sober at my
mom's and if we can course but that
there are people that are looking at and
being like you know where was the
oversight and where was the management
of this person meaning me and how could
they not know meaning the corporation
and and oh my god editors were traveling
like that and flying first-class and all
of that and shame on him for you know
someone else could have been doing this
job and I didn't write the book for
media people no you're right it you're
just telling your story I'm telling
that's why obviously it's this is this
is like a surprising five it is and it's
an annoying one but but I'm working
through it but it's it's to me details
magazine Conde Nast the publishing
company that put details magazine out
media in general are really just
characters in my book to help
contextualize my story and and and mice
to anonymize anyway most of whom exactly
I change the names of just about as many
people as I could possibly could just to
avoid dragging people into my mess yeah
it's not intended to be an expose no
absolutely no self absolutely not and so
but there are
people that are sort of like kind of
taking it taking me to task or the media
kind of as to that and and so be it I
mean that is what it is just with
respect to oversight though like I think
the the magazine was doing well this was
the thing you know and maybe it's doing
well they're leaving you alone they was
it was a time of crazy expense accounts
and you're like you know and it's living
in a hotel basically I didn't totally
count cars everywhere yeah I mean this
was that world known time and and no one
was paying attention if it was going one
no Matt you were hitting your goals and
and were exceeding them even and we were
doing really nicely and and so no one
was gonna sort of jump in and be like
hey what's going on here there was no
reason to you know and and we had I had
a ton of autonomy and and and that's
that you know and and incidentally it's
sort of I wouldn't blame or hold anyone
accountable for lack of oversight anyway
you know like I was making choices and
and and and then obviously became a
full-blown addict you know when I when I
ultimately got sober I I so this all
goes circles back to my my my then wife
who was pregnant you know at the time
with our oldest son and and she
ultimately did discover that I was doing
taking all of these pills and and and I
think did did an incredibly brave thing
which which I'm grateful for every day
which was like hey like I love you but
you need to get out of this house and
you need to deal with this but you can't
do it here I'm six months pregnant I
can't have it around me and and I I am
really grateful for that and I respect
that and I think it was a really smart
thing for her to do and I went down to
my mom's house and got sober spent two
weeks down there and you know I'm home
you know there's nothing quite like
being a you know
like a 35 year old man or person and and
going back to your mom's house and
basically just sort of like crumbling
the pieces you know which is precisely
what happened and I got sober I was down
there for two weeks I attended my first
12-step meeting I you know I called the
doctors someone in my life that I am I
took my childhood that I grew up with
who was sober said hey you need to tell
on yourself you need to call these
doctors and like I was like yes you know
like I was in I was like this is the new
me and cut off the source and I'm gonna
cut it off of the source you know and I
said called you know I was probably
seeing three or four doctors at the time
and I called all of them except for one
so - even in that moment of feeling
amazing about where I had you know where
I was how I was starting to feel being
like oh wow like I'm I'm through the
physical stuff you know I I held back
and had to re-engage with my life in New
York I had a big job that I was away
from for two weeks I had a pregnant wife
that I needed to figure out like a path
forward with and and after all this sort
of crap that I had put her through and I
was like okay I'm gonna go back to New
York I had been enrolled in an
outpatient recovery facility in New York
City to go to like you know meet
meetings you know probably every day or
four times a week and on the way back
I'm on a train I'll get on that Amtrak
train and from from Baltimore to New
York and I call and I get a prescription
and it's waiting for me at a pharmacy
and I get off the train I go right to
the pills and and I took them for a day
cunning baffling and powerful the most
cunning baffling and powerful and it
isn't such a powerful disease addiction
is that it that even while I was in
Baltimore I I made this split-second
decision while I was calling these
doctors to
to eliminate to limp the whole back hold
one back to hold one back have that out
that's how that's how powerful it is I'd
gone through so much I was out to
everything my wife had kicked me up my
pregnant wife had kicked me out all of
this stuff it didn't matter you know I
like made the decision in a like a blink
of an eye to do that and I went back to
New York and I I took pills for a day
and then I I stopped that was it
that was October 12 2007 and your son
was born shortly thereafter was it was
born in January of 2008 just three short
months from the time that I got sober
yeah that that idea of like what's your
bottom I mean the the the demoralization
of filling that script and taking those
pills after that commitment that you
made yourself I mean they always say
like you know if you want to if you want
to like really ruin your drinking and
using like get a head full of AAA and
then use and right now it's just like
you just you you've never felt worse and
and more ashamed of yourself when you do
that yeah and that's the beauty of it
yeah right because it hopefully gets you
to come back and and and in this case
for me anyway it did but 2007 sober ever
since sober ever since 13 12 13 years
its October so in October of 2014 years
so I celebrate amazing yeah it's
wonderful it's wonderful it's it has has
changed my my my life with the same sort
of force that that cartwheel did you
know it because I I live with
ingratitude now you know and I'm really
grateful to be here because I shouldn't
be and you know this this opiate
addiction kills a hundred and thirty
people a day there are a hundred and
thirty opiate related overdose deaths
every day and and I'm I'm I'm
I'm a miracle and I know that and I try
to try to be grateful for it every day I
try to do a gratitude list actually
every day I am I have this email chain
and I'm on with about 10 other guys and
it would just hit reply all and list the
things that I'm grateful for you know
and I'm super grateful for for super so
many basic things that that I used to
take for granted or I used to see normal
quote unquote normal people do all the
time
basic stuff like take the trash out and
open the mail and pay bills and shave
things like that that that I just never
did you know I never made them a
priority I they were burdensome things
to do these simple things these small
little things and now I'm sober twelve
plus years and I kid you not I still
when I take the garbage out when I open
my mail when I shave which I do almost
every day I'm still incredibly grateful
for the fact that I'm doing those things
and I in my mind celebrate them ever so
briefly as small victories they are wins
for me because I shouldn't be here to do
any of these things and shaving is is is
one that that is particularly meaningful
to me because I had gotten to a point as
an active addict where I didn't want to
shave because I couldn't stand to stand
in front of a mirror and see myself
which you have to do in order to shave
your face and I just couldn't look at
myself I felt such shame I was defeated
and and so now I shave every day and I
feel really good about yeah that's
beautiful man you know it's true I I
think one of the you know one of my
favorite things about your
dori and something that I relate to is
is your embrace of the traditional path
of 12-step and and and how much you
appreciate you know what the program has
offered you and how it's changed your
life and how you've been able to
maintain your involvement in the program
at a very immersive you know highest
priority level and I suspect that if you
were still editing details magazine you
would be there would be articles in the
magazine about you know ayahuasca and
you know new protocols and treatments
for addiction and everything we thought
we knew about addiction is wrong and
look I'm somebody who got sober in a
treatment center and you know showed up
at AAA in Los Angeles and and just
basically went in full bore you know and
it's still you know the most important
thing in my life and it's just
interesting to over the over the years
like you know I got sober 98 like to see
these trends kind of come and go and and
you know how people respond to you know
what worked for me and you know are
always kind of coming up with new and
different ways and it's like all I know
man is that like hey works right it's
been a miracle in my life like you know
the arc of my life is absurd and I am
privileged to be able to sit across with
and participate in a community of people
where I see broken people come in and
they are welcomed and embraced and loved
and cared for in the most selfless way
and I've seen life change in the most
dramatic ways possible and like that's
my experience only share your experience
yeah right I can't say hey this is the
right way to do it and this is the wrong
way to do it because I actually don't
believe that there is a right way and a
wrong way yeah I don't have it a pin I
have friends that have gotten sober and
ways to and that's fine that's awesome
that's amazing there are lots of
different paths to recovery all I can
say is that for me the 12-step program
and specifically AAA is what does it for
me
and and making meetings a priority in my
life is is incredibly important to me
because and I do it still to this day
you know you know I try to get to two or
three meetings a week you know if I can
and sometimes more if I have the ability
to do more it's incredibly incredibly
important for me because I like the way
that I approach my life now and I am far
from perfect God knows I'm far from
perfect but I am present I try to stay
healthy
I try to be accountable for my [ __ ] for
my actions for my behavior these are
things that I was a blamer
you know I would point the finger at
anyone in everyone
now I take stock in what I've done to
contribute to kind of where I am or if
some situation or argument or whatever
the case may be and for me that's been
with the help and support of the 12-step
program and the fellowship of men and
women who are in the 12-step program and
so like I said there's no one path but
this has been my path uh-huh and it's
it's been pretty stellar you know it
really has how do you think about the
tradition of anonymity now being
somebody who's written a book about this
and as somebody who you know is of the
media I have my thoughts on this are
actually sort of evolving as we speak
I believe in anonymity I think I think
it's a very individual I think it's a
big decision if you choose to break your
anonymity and and and speak openly about
your recovery I think that we we live in
a culture that I think the stigma is
real and and I think it's important for
me to say that and I'm hoping as our
others who speak publicly about their
addiction and alcoholism
Toodee stigmatize this and we
know that this isn't a moral failure
this is this is a condition this is part
of the human condition this isn't this
is a disease and I think it's it's been
categorized as such you know by the
American Medical Association this is
this is a real thing this isn't a lack
of willpower this isn't someone that
just can't get it together man come on
like it isn't though it's not that and
so lots of people have come come out and
and and disclosed that they're addicts
or alcoholics and and and I think and
I'm happy to have done it I'm happy to
have written this book and share my
story in an effort to show people that
either are struggling with this or it's
touching their lives in some way that
there is hope because I truly believe
and we hear a lot of people say this if
I can do it
meaning find sobriety anyone can that
said I think the stigma is real and I
think that there are people out there
that are like will publicly be like oh
man awesome you wrote this book that's
super brave and I know this is gonna
help a lot of people you know but but I
think privately are are judging I really
do believe that not everyone and of
course you know but I I just I think
that this is gonna be a tough nut to
crack you know I really do and and again
I'm I'm sharing my story to help crack
that nut if you will you know but but I
think I think in 2020 like the stigma is
is real you know and and and I encourage
people to ask for help you know and if
you I was terrified to ask for help I
didn't want to lose this plum job that I
had which by the way I kept for an
additional eight years after I got sober
right but I was terrified I was gonna
lose that I didn't want to lose my
marriage you know and I ultimately ended
up getting divorce but in that in that
moment I was about to be a dad I didn't
want to lose that and I didn't want
people to judge me I didn't want people
to go oh my god he's an addict and and
think that there's there's a lot of that
so I'm sharing my story too and as have
others of course to work toward de
stigmatizing this this addiction mmm-hmm
what is your sense of what can be done
about the opioid crisis I mean it's dark
it is dark and it is devastating
communities whole communities in this
country and it's really sweeping across
our country in in in an incredibly
powerful way I think we need to talk
about it
and I think we have to be careful also
right we're in an election cycle so we
hear it come up at debates and we hear
yes we're gonna fight this opioid
epidemic and yes we're gonna crush it
and and we're hard at work on it and and
and and that to some degree may be true
and I think it's nice that it's being
mentioned I think it's important that
it's being mentioned but I think in
order to really see an impact to make an
impact here we have to do a number of
things I think we need to focus on
prevention I think we need to focus on
education I think we need to focus on
treatment I think we need to I you know
as you pointed out you know had the
luxury and the privilege I had have had
a privileged life and I know that and I
don't make excuses for that and I but I
I understand that I'm really aware of
that and I'm I'm aware of the fact that
even getting sober I had family and mom
and and and family and mom and a dad and
brother and a stepfather and and all
these people that open their arms and
brought me home David Copperfield if we
didn't talk about including the magician
David Copperfield like who that's that's
a high privilege yep David Copperfield
come and stay at my place the factors
heavily into my story I had that I had
the ability to go to an outpatient
program so so with respect to treatment
you know I really believed that it can't
be easier to get the drug than it is to
get the treatment and you know and in
huge portions of this country that's
precisely the case it's just so much
easier to find
more drugs than it is to find treatment
and so there need to be strong treatment
options across this country even if it's
pure based treatment 12-step whatever
the case may be where people can can go
to get help and don't have to spend and
don't have to do anything I had the
luxury of being able to do that there
are people that go off to incredibly
expensive rehabs and they can afford to
do that or have insurance that covers
that and that's wonderful and I
encourage you to do that if you have the
resources to do that but but you know
creating treatment options that are
available to everyone that is impacted
by this in this country because this
this opioid epidemic is impacting
everyone it doesn't discriminate right
it's the great equalizer man I was in
New York City media executive grossly
overpaid I had a great life that didn't
matter to impacting absolutely everyone
and there are those that that need
treatment options that don't get them so
I think that's really important and I
think you know federal appropriations
need to sort of be earmarked for that
and they need to be long-term not like
yeah we're gonna throw a couple years
worth of funding here and see where
things go and we're gonna you know I
think this is this is real and it is
incredibly incredibly hard to stop yeah
I think one of the things dr. drew said
in your conversation was we need to make
treatment as available as the drugs
themselves right like it needs to be
freely available and accessible I mean
out here in Malibu
I think Malibu has the highest
percentage of like halfway houses and
rehabs of anywhere in the country so
many of them are real estate plays like
they get these fancy houses and they
know that they can rent these rooms out
at an insane price and it just becomes
these profit centers that really aren't
rooted in you know the the proper
motivation to help people and help
people that can't afford this kind of
thing or on top of that are at times
staffed by people that aren't as
qualified as they need to be to offer
that help yeah hundred percent what is
your daily kind of
talked about your gratitude list and and
you know going to a couple of meetings a
week but like what is the daily practice
for you so the daily practice for me
starts with gratitude like I said I
think you know I am grateful for every
day that I have because I really don't
think that I should still be here
and so I I take a minute and and take
stock of that you know and or at least
try to every day I've I'm working toward
almost just told you a lie I was like I
meditate every day no I don't just write
there like that instance of you almost
saying something and catching yourself
like that's sobriety yeah yeah right I
mean calling myself out on my own
[ __ ] right tonight own self be true
like it starts with it absolutely must
start with being honest with yourself
right and and and that's that to me is
is everything you know like am I being a
good human today you know like am i
engaging in meaningful ways with people
and am i apologizing if I owe someone an
apology am i judging someone when I
shouldn't be judging them because Jesus
the Lord knows like Who am I to judge
right so it's just sort of like keeping
myself in check so so right I don't
meditate every day I don't come close to
meditating every day but I am trying to
bring meditation into my life more and
more because it is like a game changer
when when I'm able to do it yeah you
know so gratitude meditation I try to
take some time to to have like a strong
spiritual connection and just sort of
acknowledge that like I'm here for for a
reason I try to be super present now
I was never present I lived a life of
not showing up in any way emotionally
personally physically I just was never
there and so I try to be present in in
every way that I possibly can today and
and show up for people when I say I'm
gonna show up for them you know
addiction is is lonely and terrifying at
times and so I I if I can be present for
people if I can be present for myself
and more than anything else I'm present
for my kids man I'm a sober dad right
and you have three kids I have three
sons and they've only ever known me as a
sober man and that is like the greatest
gift of sobriety for me and I work I
work to earn that and deserve that every
day being a dad is why I believe I was
given a second excuse me it's hard for
me I could even get emotional is why I
believe I'm I'm here and so I try to be
super super present for them I try to
eat healthy when I can you know you know
sort of like don't want to open that can
of worms with you your diet during the
heavy pill-popping phase is insane yeah
it was really out of control and it was
really unhealthy and and could have
killed me just as quickly as the
addiction could have I was microwaving
Ben and Jerry's ice cream and just
chugging it right from the right from
the container you know so you know try
to be I try to be healthy man and I try
to stay small you know I tried to to to
live like be really good with with with
living like a good small life you know
and a friend of mine
Laura McGowan has recently written a
memoir called we are the luckiest and
this chapter in there where she talks
about sitting down with someone else in
recovery who've been an old-timer you
know and she's new and [ __ ] miserable
and missing her old life and she sits
down at this restaurant with this person
who says like had it like what's your
life like today and
and I'm completely bastardizing her
beautiful this chapter in her book but
and this woman says I have a nice little
life and at first Lara's like who wants
that you know I have a nice little life
now
and and I'm you know so thank you for
that Laura and I'm I'm you know I'm good
beautiful in writing the book who were
like you know there's a whole genre of
you know addiction yarns out there like
some good some not so good like I would
imagine like Burroughs he you know I
will say when I was writing a book I
stayed away from them because I didn't
want to be overly influenced in any way
be influenced by what I was reading
uh-huh and so I kept kept away from them
that said it there are people that have
written I think quite beautifully about
about addiction and about recovery and
and certainly augusten burroughs is one
of those people I think Gustin has done
it also with great humor which is which
I which i think is important and but
there's there's there's so many great
works out there they have a car I think
did it masterfully and and they're there
there are others Maryke are there there
are there are there many others and what
was the motivation in writing this book
now I mean you've been sober for a while
at this point like how did this come
about I had heard of all of the vast
riches that befall authors the ultimate
get-rich-quick see exactly I just I felt
like I had stories to share if for no
other reason I wanted to just put them
down on paper to share with my kids one
day I started writing them and and and
it turned into a book I think I think
it's I think it's really important for
people to just know that there
path out and I and and because when I
was actively using I would look at these
books and I would hear stories I
remember really quite vividly being an
active addict and like just being zonked
out on pills and like sitting on my sofa
with probably like a cigarette like
burning down to my knuckles you know and
and you know empty you know Ben and
Jerry's containers you know around me it
wasn't pretty I'm watching like on some
entertainment TV show Entertainment
Tonight or something like that like this
celebrity like going into rehab you know
and I remember thirty days later sitting
on that sofa I had moved but it would
look like I did hadn't and and seeing
the report so and so out of rehab and
you know you know openly publicly
addressing for the first time you know
their their new recovery and thinking oh
my god like I could have done it in
these thirty nine period of time where
you hadn't moved I could I could have
done it and I would feel worse and worse
about myself you know because I wanted
to stop I was ready I really was
desperate to stop so my point is I think
people sharing their their stories helps
it didn't help get me off that couch it
didn't help me from stop me from going
to getting the next series of
prescriptions but the seed was it was
yeah it was a domino and in in that
process it was right so if my book can
can be that for someone I think that's
important I also think that it's
important for people that don't know
addiction that that haven't lived with
it or been exposed to it through a
family member or loved one just to see a
glimpse into what what it looks like and
so that that was part of the motivating
factor also is like hey take a look at
at how awful this can get and try to
understand that this is this is really
all consuming and this book will give
you a glimpse of that well with a
hundred and thirty people dying every
single day
from this very condition none of us are
more than one or two people away from
somebody who is currently suffering from
this so the time you know is now for
this conversation more than ever and the
need for solutions
you know begins with understanding and
understanding means you know wrapping
your head around the experience of what
it is like to endure something like this
so I applaud you for writing the book
and I think the best way to land this
plane is to have you kind of speak to
the addict to perhaps is listening right
now that person who might be on the
couch you know what's the Ben and
Jerry's containers listening to this but
unsure about what that first step looks
like I think that that first step looks
like acknowledging that you are an
addict and and for me I struggled with
that for a long time and then I
eventually acknowledged that I was an
addict while I was still using and I
used for a while longer after that but
to acknowledge I mean it's it's really
simplify it to a now acknowledge of
powerlessness over over this addiction
there's nothing that you it's not gonna
go away on its own and you need to step
up and say okay I'm I'm I'm ready you
have to be ready and you have to step
forward and say I'm ready I think that's
the most important first step is to
acknowledge it and to and to reach out
and ask for help you don't have to do it
publicly you don't have to tweet about
it or post about it but you you should
reach out and ask for help because you
cannot do it alone it is incredibly
difficult to do it alone and I never
everybody tries first yeah try it and
until they realize it's it's not gonna
work so so my advice to that person
would be okay let's own this like this
is where you are and and let's ask for
help because help is there and and and I
was was welcomed into a community of
people into the recovery community in
ways that I never ever thought would it
would have been possible and just the
pure realization that your situation is
not unique right
like there's this idea like that
whatever you're enduring and suffering
is is is something that no other human
being could possibly understand that's
that's a fact
right that you're there and you're you
are thinking to yourself I understand
that people get sober from this I
understand people have done it but no
one is as bad off as I am and and no one
like you know it hasn't gotten this bad
with anyone else on the face of the
earth and so it's pointless for me to to
step forward and say okay I'm gonna go
ahead and and take some action here and
that's just absolute [ __ ] right like
we are run-of-the-mill
garden-variety dime-a-dozen drug addicts
whether or not you know like that's
what's at the core of my book quite
frankly is that there's all this weird
crazy stuff I had access to all of these
people and and David Copperfield and and
right you're the ultimate like don't you
know who I think I am and this mashup of
like you know and it's sort of an
overinflated ego with massive insecurity
absolutely that's precisely what I was
but at its core I'm I'm a I'm a common
drug addict and and it's an incredibly
common story and and there there is a
path out but no one else can put you on
that path you have to be willing to say
okay I'm ready to sort of start my walk
down this path and no one can say it for
you I can't say it for you parents can't
say it for you wives children husbands
it just it's not gonna happen until
you're ready to say alright let's do
this right and so what about the person
who's listening who has that person in
their life that's suffering and they
feel powerless not to help that person I
mean I get tons of emails like this like
I don't know what to do my spouse my
boyfriend my girl well I get a lot of
yeah and it's like you know you you kind
of spoke to it already it's it's about
willingness and willingness is something
that you cannot compel in another
individual short of their willingness
you're pretty limited in how you can you
know show up for somebody in this
situation you
it's it's it's it's an awful position to
be in to watch someone that you love and
care about you know slowly kill
themselves because that's precisely
what's happening and worse hear them
deny it and get angry at you for
suggesting it you know so I have a
tremendous amount of love and respect
for the people that are in the lives of
addicts and and stay in those lives and
continue to be loving and supportive and
I admire that and I'm grateful so
grateful that there are people out there
like that I think it's incredibly
important to to make sure that you're
not enabling an addict you know it can
be really easy to do that and I don't
recommend doing that but I also don't
recommend shutting them out of your life
I think there's there's there's some
in-between and that's where you should
live be supportive don't stop loving and
take care of yourself in the meantime
and absolutely you know rightly as you
say anytime you get on a plane you know
make sure your your oxygen mask is on
first before you you know go to help
others like take care of yourself and
and that is incredibly important but
listen you know call them out on their
[ __ ] also you know forgive the language
but like don't just see see behavior
that is telling and off and ignore it
you know call them on it don't do it in
an aggressive way but call them on it
let them know that you're on to them
they're gonna deny it they're gonna lie
to you but you know be loving and
supportive but don't let them get away
with in 100% we did it we did it man
it's good yeah it was great I was pretty
good how you feel I feel really good all
right we're really good I feel I don't
feel like you did when you sat next to
dr. drew on that flight and he killed
your hi who's the ultimate buzzkill dr.
drew all right I feel I think the only
thing that could like make this even one
notch better would be like a little Rick
Springfield to just take it right well
there's a guitar behind you if you want
to play it nothing it you're more than
welcome to
next time alright man thanks so the book
is called as needed for pain as I said I
love a good addiction yarn and I'm not
done with this book yet I'm just
cracking into it but it's quite a yarn
so congratulations on it I think it's
going to help a lot of people check it
out even if you just want to read about
stories with rock stars in the back of
limos or you're trying to cop heroin in
cars or park and I mean there's a lot of
banana [ __ ] in this book and it's super
entertaining but also really speaks to
the heart of you know what this disease
is and and how to see your way through
it so thank you for your service thanks
a lot man I appreciate all right man and
if you want to connect with with Dan
what's the best way Dan at Dan Perez and
why on Twitter so right so at Dan Paris
and why there's another thing like you
didn't read your audiobook I know I did
and the guy says Perez no and I know
it's per I have such an issue with that
but it is what it is how can you read
your audio but you know III per columns
like we really want to have an actor do
this and I was like okay they told me
not to and I was like no way and my
editor was like if you really want but
we recommend I was like all right
whatever and so I should have but so
it's it's Dan Paris
so at Instagram it's Dan underscore
Paris P or ES and Twitter it's at Dan
Paris also pers and why and yeah that's
where all right cool man and chef we
missed you
yeah Jeff next time we'll do it all
three of us together all right peace